ed est un adolescent il vit dans une
cité il a une bande d'amis un jeune
garçon comme tous ceux de son âge ou
presque
voilà un deal en fauteuil roulant et
puis je me suis dit mais ouais mais il a
des copains qui on m'a dit que c'était
tabou de parler du handicap
alors j'ai rajouté du tableau j'ai fait
un gros black sam in obese un petit
maghrébins ilena segade chant guinée
malvoyants
je voulais aussi parler du handicap
invisible donc j'ai fait tommy tommy les
défis seront légèrement autistes
cette année la banda est fête ses 10 ans
il s'agit de la première bande dessinée
à mettre en scène des héros ordinaires
handicapé son auteur était mardi 8 mars
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin pour une séance de dédicaces
dans le cadre des journées andy fac sa
venue était organisée par l'association
étudiante cap évasion
je pense que c'est un bon vecteur parce
que c'est une bande dessinée qui peut
s'adresser autant aux adultes qu'aux
enfants trouvent ça bien de sensibiliser
les gens dès leur plus jeune âge puisque
ça évite que les préjugés s'installe
durablement via la bd ça permet à chacun
de s'approprier les personnages
s'approprier l'histoire s'approprient
les situations et je pense que c'est
vraiment un très bon média et c'est très
bien très bien amenée dans les planches
parler du monde du handicap 127 et avec
un humour engagé une recette qui
fonctionne pour faire changer les
mentalités
les choses s'améliorent le regard
s'améliorent surtout on en parle de plus
en plus parler du handicap c'est faire
avancer la cause du handicap montrer le
handicap c'est faire avancer la cause du
handicap
voilà le sentiment plus j'ai la bande
dessinée a reçu le prix handi livre du
meilleur ouvrage jeunesse en 2007
le tome 5 de la banda aide est déjà en
préparation